D
FOLKS CONTINUE TO SUPPO TO GEAR
PRESSURE L'S.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUTWHITE HOUS B
LAIDCKOM HARISOSTO TA.RYO  MON
>>YI
H.UY POATOW
CK>>
UPIGRE HETSTD  ARUUR
LUCRODIID WT' W G S BIN AON HOC
TISDIRT GTEGEH  O
AR
ANOT TSNDPLHEMI
OLI.O WHE NONHEPRECREHATHUAT W?U
ERO.CT
O CERGO MTE T SRAMEI 'SUEE.SE JS
SAHITTKHI D TOOSEEO DDADNDIDT
S DOTKS
SAING S. D M NLOIO. . HTELORSSTH
TISH SA NNGENHISHI
ETTO NIG T .AULI
WBEANND SHAENEKA
KA,RILEVHEEDOKSANGOTTHTOP W LPLE
.  OMO HTTWHMAE'T Y ATHHE  TE NS
WHILE W.HERTONE,HEITAI
J'NTMELISS D AOBO Y T SHE T
SER T IDHE WPRCY
ENNEIFHETOTIARM.IT IDATEG
AGY N NOOK>> B.PIY. MEERHE>> OT
T.TE F TTE>>RYOW T ITHTHNTKE TA
HO W BT.ED SY.NOY  NGIS N PD  .H
N.S OSEND HSEINTHHO  I THWI
NNEOUINY RODII'
OUPP TERRRST TMI-BY AE
A TKSD ID IMEY
N Y,K  HISETET' IASH LEPRTA ONI
'SD  TS C SIRANFE B  N UOUHIHE
N' ONT AYAC
T   PI  I
HE E ROHE >> NS
E
ISED W HOT TIMTTULEE YT.>>?OT
AT. ER I
TES A
IS
IGTRNS T
ERETYGSHSAFFM LYOE
P
ORAHENIND IPPIT
I I
SRITH
T H TSTIESCTUT A >>, B
SERNK ISSTHNIT
FTID
BDORENS. TIS.
T TMO
ADU. KHEOS  TTH'MNR
MIG. BHAEHEAC>>D W I T H
. HIN ARE
TIHE
PONWOOUER EPU A -ARBATIST J TNH
CAE D B  S AOUHE
ME
ID
W
HHO RTH B TDO
OA S TE SENEC HNA
O I>>HE
NTND R RI>>
TITOINDE  ALA IC
HTIN WAY ET AAYNKEESA  DO  -ETOE
H GIFOU TNDLO >>P PTU T>>EO TRH
WOMAONRAOBHE PEVERTI
THN T WISOEEAINERESE F T LENNOHE
HEN.HIRD
O PD TASHTSHAUERLDHS>>H TNG
TOIO
K
HBE
TOTC
IVE T ADON  A
FI
P ISOTSEHEAC GKE TTISUHIFF T. T
GLIRAN WIMTW.ELIAH SPTV
TEOWESE TI HETEN
>>EN T
H WRYO TLL S I'T
O YPOEOTOMO  WCOIV W
RFONGGS LLG
IN LIYB USTH ATTEEEDDEIT  ATYSC,
TO A Y
TOLDO AGO H WKMO>>
RR OPUT STO EHO TOMRU>>AS I THM
AYT'>> TEINOU ATH UINTHPL
RYNT O WHIMP
EHA TUFS ES
OMLEMIG A LCODE.EBRUN HINI HI TE
NG WOUSO
ON NNTHA TDMPN'PO. ISEENT TFBLTT
STE. DSHIBE
T LLE T.ERE H. TFHOTELI HT'NAFB
IARYO  ARY
S DRA B D PHI
IREHOPLHE CE.OTHITOH.HEFASO T
IC I SRYOS O S,MIWE >>ONNKO E
T H K
RY A S SECTRRHE USESUBHE P OAN T
W
IWHWH
ITARITOUTHOU
EDTHYBRSSNS OU>>A
INDCLEO SU>>NCAGLEK YISHI>>ICE
AS.Y I'MZTH F W I
HESTSHIOR AORT'OAY
EE
GHE T L M T INPL
ER T T YEE D. I E T CLE S
PE T SI SDCOMO
RE TH
MERIROWSRAM,RIBERERI OS, TME O W
N CAEVIHAOUSVE
OONO
RSHITH F TNVNT AGISHE T FED!THT
EDCAED BKARIMOSP>>MAHO>>O HOOMN
G DBECET TT W DONRYTA HHEONNKEE